the biggest debate at the daily wire is
not over gender
it's not over the 2024 race and it's not
over immigration or the biggest debate
aliens
some people
like my colleague Matt Walsh say that
aliens are real E.T comes down abducts
people prowls around Little Green Men
and some people
are correct
such as yours truly observes that ET is
fake it's not real
we are not alone in the universe but as
far as corporeal beings go with rational
Souls we are alone and that when people
see these unidentified flying objects
and when they think they encounter the
little green man they're most likely
just talking to demons and
it's amazing people make fun of me for
this
but the reason people make fun of me for
this point of view
is because they are moderns they're
modern secular Libs and aliens are
they're just demons for modern lib
people who can't imagine that there's
such a thing as metaphysical reality so
it's for people who are materialists who
who think that everything that's real
has to be flesh and blood which
obviously isn't true you know some of
the most important things in life are
not Material hopes dreams love
mathematics you know there are plenty of
things that are metaphysic the moral
order but we have convinced ourselves in
this
unsophisticated day and age that it's
all got to be physical and so
so even the celestial beings have to be
physical they can't be uh merely
spiritual now there's a fella by the
name of Luis Elizondo this is reported
by the New York Post although I got to
give a hat tip to Pope had here a great
sub stack writer and Tweeter who called
my attention to this Louis Louis
Elizondo is a Former Intelligence
officer with the Department of Defense
he claims he was the director of aatip
the pentagon's UFO program from 2010 to
2017. former Senate Majority Leader
Harry Reid has defended this guy and
said he actually was pretty prominent in
the government working on these things
here's what he had to say
I had one
I remember conversation very well
um this is a person I respected
tremendously very very senior person
he's told me he said Lou I want you to
stop stop doing this
I said okay sir I I certainly can't but
may ask why and he says well we already
know what it is now at that moment I I
honestly thought maybe it was our own
technology and I was running up against
some super uber secret sap and uh you
know they were telling me to stop and I
said okay sir so so it's ours
and he said no
that's not what I'm saying and he said
he asked me Point Blank have you read
your Bible lately
and I wasn't quite sure where he was
going with that I said well sir I I
think I know what it says where are you
going with this
and he said well then you would know
that these things are are demonic and we
should not be pursuing them yeah and uh
I I he was he wasn't kidding me but
that's exactly how how he felt so this
is a pentagon this is a Department of
Defense
official uh saying stop looking at UFOs
because they're demonic
correct
correct correct not only is this senior
apparently respectable Pentagon official
who is so admirable that one of the guys
who was running the UFO office there
really looked up to this guy but it's
correct in that that's obviously what
these things are now when you want to
fight off terrestrial things
like I don't know uh unlit cigars and
you know little Vermin and uh charcoal
you've got to go check out Grill Blazer
right now go to grillblazer.com grill
Blazers Grill duns are designed to do
everything from expertly searing your
Meats to lighting charcoal grills wood
stoves outdoor fireplaces and just about
anything you can think of that you would
need high power fire to use for your
problem this would also include cigars
as I have shown once or twice though
that is not recommended at home grow
Blazers offers two types of Grill guns
the grill gun basic is a high power
propane torch designed to Light charcoal
and wood grills and smokers burns up to
3 600 Degrees it's a 30 inch flame is
for anything you need the big bad torch
to do and I mean anything the SUV gun
has a shorter Barrel perfect for
professional Culinary Kitchen uses from
gently caramelizing roulette or other
sugars and fruits to rapidly searing
steaks outside on the grill you using
the grill gun may result in extreme
Grill Envy from your neighbors so user
caution is advised get your grill gun
from Grill Blazers today and let the
grilling Adventures begin visit
grillblazer.com and use promo code
Knolls for 15 off your order that is
grillblazer.com
promo code nulls for 15 off your order
right now go to puretalk.com Knowles one
company that I'm very proud to stand
behind a company that's proud to stand
behind us in our country
Pure Talk veteran owned with a 100
American Workforce they share our
beliefs that is why Pure Talk is the
official cell phone wireless provider of
the daily wire but that is not the only
reason
Pure Talk also happens to be the most
Dependable 5G Network in the US they're
a top tier provider and a fraction of
the cost of those other companies you
know those companies ATT Verizon
T-Mobile
companies that do not care about you or
what you believe mix and match your
plans to fit every person in your family
choose from talk text and 5G data for
just 20 bucks a month all the way up to
unlimited data with a mobile hotspot
just 55 a month I guarantee that's less
than you're paying for that right now
you vote with how you spend your money
stop supporting woke wireless companies
that do not support you go to
puretalk.com Knowles you get great
coverage and save while you're doing it
go to puretalk.com Knowles just save an
additional 50 off your first month
because they actually value you that is
puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk Wireless
buy Americans for Americans the aliens
are demonic now what's interesting is
this guy in this interview from a couple
of years ago that not a lot of people
seem to have found uh this guy
seems to disagree with the respected
more senior Pentagon official who said
the stuff's demonic we shouldn't be
looking into it and this guy says no
we've got to look into it we've got to
go get all the data we've got to probe
this stuff we got to find out what's
really going on
and my question is why why do we have to
do that
curiosity is not a virtue
why should we do that there is more in
Heaven and Earth Horatio than is dreamed
of in our philosophy and certainly the
desiccated modern philosophy that
ignores metaphysical things
why why are we going to do this if if
there were which there is not a super
race of extremely intelligent E.T
they're coming and they can mess with us
and they can probe us and they can cross
the Galaxy and then go faster than the
speed of lightning and do all this crazy
stuff their technology is so much more
advanced than ours is
then we're not going to beat them
you know that'd be like a squirrel
trying to beat an army of human beings I
mean we're just if we're that much
stupider than these things then we're
obviously not going to beat them
if
they're demons then we should want
nothing to do with them
C.S Lewis had a good bit on demons which
is he said the right attitude toward
demons is that you've you should know
that they exist because there is
spiritual reality we
we are Body and Soul we're hylomorphic
composite beings with a rational Soul
that's why we have an appetite we have
to eat food and drink water to sustain
ourselves man does not live by bread
alone and we can use our abstract reason
and moral judgment to think of things
like um Justice or art or culture or
Opera I don't know right we can we can
do both those things
certain beings are
are purely physical they don't have a
rational so like a rock
even the animals they don't they don't
have abstract reason we don't put them
on trial we don't put a dog on trial
when he bites you okay that's why and
then on the other side of things there
are beings that are purely physical
I ideas are physical and angels and
demons are physical too and everyone has
known this for all of history until
modern Western liberal secular people
and like a hundred years ago so
if they are demons then C.S Lewis points
out the right attitude is know that they
exist be on guard you know they're
trying to uh prey on Souls tear you down
to Hell and give you a bad eternity and
so we should know that but we shouldn't
be too curious about them so it's kind
of like bugs I don't know you've got
bugs in your house
you've got to be aware of that and take
care of the problem and like keep them
from coming in and kill the ones that
are there
but you don't want to spend a lot of
time with them you know you don't want
to spend your whole day thinking about
the bugs being around the bugs you just
want to get rid of them okay and that's
how I feel about
aliens who are really demons as the
Pentagon even admits boy wasn't that a
great clip make sure you subscribe here
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles show channel before we're nuked
from orbit see you next time